[Music]
so you're loosening up a little bit now
I'm not changing Tate a beautiful pivot
to score
he's shooting 46% from the free-throw
line this season never obviously been a
good free throw shooter Tatum Heights
just a splendid spinnable from Jason
Tate of thick and Rawls Kuzma louses
them to use the screen and then the spin
gets deep in the paint and Mike
oftentimes in the past
Tatum would have taken a step back jump
just been a really solid backup boiling
Tatum inside high off the glass Tatum
against Caruso spins gets inside on
thanks at home
Boise up impressive ask it when he gets
a matchup he likes spins off of Caruso
good help by Howard but a better finish
Tatum again it just gets inside oh my
Wow
folk humble right now and confident on
the offensive end one-on-one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Danny Green an excellent defender trying
her Assam Tatum creates some space nails
a three is on another level on the
offensive end
pick-and-roll you lay back as a big man
he comes off he sees the rim detain him
using that screen again by theis shoots
over Davis knocks another three-pound
Jason Tatum after he gets the switch
that's a tough shot over one of the best
defensive players in the NBA the shot
making in this league right now is off
the charts it really is my brown on
LeBron James pass stolen by Marcus smart
I hate to Tate him one man to beat
oh and he throws it down run by the
Celtics Jason Tate up having his way
decides to go green Tatum wide open puts
it in
Jason Tatum with 25 and Frank Vogel
wants timeout about all of the stop push
it in transition
good basketball three Ball corner pocket
Davis the season 32% from downtown
Tatom outside again Jason Tatum with us
for three here you'll see McGee leave
the double team doesn't initially a good
job and then Tatum with the step-back
[Music]
[Applause]
drives away from the double teams banks
at home this is a brilliant performance
from Jason Tate